the office first debuted in 2005 and is
just as popular today
as it's ever been that's why streaming
platform peacock
is making the office its feature show
with extras and never before seen
footage
our doug culk spoke with some of the
classic cast members in today's
entertainment report
[Music]
all right so i'm a massive fan of this
show so i wanted to find an angle and
talk to the cast members about something
that intrigued me
in browsing peacock i found it like that
shirt doug
nice shirt i brought mine too baby oh i
love it
yeah thanks you know and i'm i'm gonna
suck it 2.0 it's coming back
it's there is so much on the peacock
network when it comes to the office i
mean it is office central
it totally is it's nuts one of the
extras that i was looking at was the
audition process
they go um michael we have never worked
in a place like this before
i mean you uh are a riot
take me back to the fall of 2003 uh was
there anything
that you wanted to add to the agenda
what i was most fascinated with was how
many
big names auditioned for these parts
crazy right i'm a sales rep
which means that my job is to speak to
clients
um bob odenkirk auditioned for the part
of michael scott
sometimes we probably play hard when we
should be working hard but that's
probably my fault but
fire me seth rogen dwight if you're in
the field
you can clean the man's wound by taking
a whiz on it that is actually
in first aid books written by the red
cross
i'm trained in this uh from being a
sheriff's deputy
judah freelander for dwight check this
out see this
it's 90 red hot peppers imported from
cuba
i mean like eric stonestreet auditioned
for the part of kevin
it's boring isn't it just staying home
watching tv
every night uh yeah for me i like it
catherine han pam crazy frankly i spent
the first
month trying to uh remind
my boss that there is no why in paper
they gave me
lines for stanley you trust me yes or no
yes i trust you they just had us reading
like generic parts isn't it so fun
watching people's auditions for other
parts
i love that like you know and you see
like okay
you see why they don't get hired but you
also see their essence and why they're
who they are if we can supply it to them
and
if they can uh purchase it and i'm
boring myself just talking about it i
thought adam scott nailed jim
you know it's so funny but like there's
some quality of
krasinski that's different than adam
scott and
i'm boring myself just talking about
and you know that's why he ends up on
parks and rec the office seasons one and
two are streaming
free through peacock the rest through
subscription
with your entertainment report i'm doug
kolk
all right i just found a number of
people in this studio have never seen
the office
they need to start watching it tonight
it's not allowed
all right moving on dory is missing and
it's up to her friends to find her in
the new season of search party
the show picks up after last season's
cliffhanger ending that saw dory
kidnapped after she was found in a sit
in a murder trial
well now drew elliott and portia have to
figure out who took dory
susan sarandon and busy phillips joined
the cast the
fourth season of search party premieres
on hbo max tomorrow
you was in the plane accident
you were the only one found
a man is held captive by a woman
performing a sinister ritual in the new
thriller spell
omari hardwick stars is the man who
wakes up stranded
in the attic after surviving a plane
crash he soon learns his host played by
loretta devine is using him
to carry out a magic ritual spell is
available from paramount
on blu-ray and dvd which one of my songs
is your favorite song
science fruit it's a song about
important things you know
things that are going on in the country
andre day takes on the role of a jazz
legend in the new trailer for the united
states versus billie holiday
the movie from director lee daniels
tells the story of singer billy holliday
who was targeted by the federal
government
in an effort to stop her from singing
her controversial and heart-wrenching
ballad strange fruit
the united states first billie holiday
premieres on hulu
february 26th